yeah i mean i mean
we met you through mutual friends but
like you know when you you know when you
meet someone in your life and you just
think like wow you're one of the most
interesting people i've ever met thank
you because like you're jan's one of
those people who you when whenever you
go to a party whenever you speak to him
he'll have a new story every [ __ ]
time and like i don't know how you do it
but like because we've hung out so many
times and every time we hang out you
come out with a new story about
something that's happened in your life
even on this podcast there's so many
questions i want to ask about your just
like life experience here in japan
because like unlike
any of our previous guests jan doesn't
have an internet presence true yeah yes
yes yes yes so understandable that uh he
is a bit nervous so go go ease in it go
easy on him but it's also like how often
do you just like come across a dude who
used to be a host yeah because like i
feel that's just like a part of like
japanese subculture life that you just
don't hear about right yeah it seems
very very japanese and from what i saw
is extremely japanese yeah the also the
only i feel the only time you would ever
get to know a host is if you yourself
end up going to a host club enough that
you get to know a host right and i mean
the three of us don't i mean almost no
foreigners become hosts anyway like even
if you're halfway like me yeah yeah no
one really like applies to become one
yeah so you're half turkish half
champion half cherokee of japanese so
if any turkish people watching what's up
when turkey's represent let's go oh you
got him man is that is that part of
turkish culture because hell yeah at any
time any time we go out and with jan he
meets he meets another turkish person
for sure it's like that
and like you get free [ __ ] and like you
take care of them they take care of you
and i'm just like what is going on it's
like the world's strongest magnets
they're just like from distance they're
like oh there you are i remember we had
a restaurant one time and they were like
you gotta leave in like one hour and
then um the the the guy the manager of
the restaurant was turkish and he was
also named jam
was like that's right it was like the
moment that he found that out it was
like the guy was like oh no no you stay
as long as you want
whatever you want to do
you know it's like what what is this bro
what is this this is insane they they
actually wanted to move us if you
remember yeah oh yeah
so i think we managed to stay on in our
spot like they moved the guests away you
know yeah
actually not like people [ __ ] booked
that place you know i'm like we're going
over our time and then they told the
guests like oh dude these guys you know
they're not gonna move how about you
let's go there okay i mean japanese
people are like yeah they go to that
guest like are you a jan i didn't think
so
i i think where if you hang out with you
one thing you notice is that uh yeah
you're not very japanese in certain ways
[Music]
i hope so but like you should that's but
that's almost you know being a host
requires you to be extremely extroverted
yeah and i think that applies to you
i've never seen someone haggle in japan
yeah but this man
this man
i i didn't even know you were like
allowed to haggle in japan until i saw
january but hey you gotta try it right
and then see what happens yeah right but
like just just based on like just
pre-assumptions of how japanese like you
know that kind of stuff in japan works
right it's like i i was watching you
haggle for the first time like i was
scared i was like you're doing something
illegal yeah yeah
because it just looks so wrong yeah i'm
just like sometimes you go out with jan
and i'm just like i didn't know you
could do this yeah because it just
wasn't part of like the rule sets that i
was taught
in japanese culture but i mean i guess
that's how you found yourself in a
position like becoming a host i mean you
know it's yeah yeah we should go we
should go like the backstory of how jam
i guess how you
first of all like ended up coming to
japan sure because you were you born in
japan i know i was born in turkey
actually okay so i was born and raised
in turkey until i was like 16. um
japanese school until seventh grade and
then international school until 10th
grade and then i moved to united arab
emirates dubai that's how
will say okay so i was in dubai for two
years came back to turkey for uni for
two years
went to czech republic and then on my
final year i went to joche so tokyo all
right i graduated here and then decided
to stay here so i was in jochi um and
then you know what is that what
graduation
yeah
yeah or is it just a united states yeah
it's like a central central tokyo
university university bro like one of
the four you know hottest chicks in
tokyo that's that's what they say
inshallah university what are they
called university the hottest chick no
no they there's like talk
in terms of hottest girls
so we clearly know why he decided to go
to this uni so you were born a host i
guess yeah no okay so i'm a [ __ ]
introvert guys shut up bro
actually
that's the biggest lie of the century
this guy has been on youtube for five
minutes yeah he's claiming to be an
introvert
come on like actual introverts watching
this show like get the [ __ ] out of here
dude like you are not one of us
like
the intel the internet has ruined the
term introvert yeah because now everyone
claims to be an introvert okay now we
have a little [ __ ] heart you can't
just say you're an introvert to try and
be humble because that doesn't work that
way what's your justification sorry tell
us why why are you an introvert all
right so
for example
i love just being by myself who doesn't
okay you know see the thing is like you
know i feel the need to hang out
you know i understand that yeah
because if i don't i don't get to make
new friends i don't get to do fun stuff
yeah yeah but when i'm like outside
hanging out with people i should turn up
like 95 of the time i'm always like
i'd rather be at home play you know
league of legends or some [ __ ] or you
know like anymore that doesn't make you
an introvert that just makes you
unsociable
i don't even want to play league you
know
i definitely don't know maybe he is
introverted
dude that's what i'm saying bro like
you're not i i do spend a lot of time
outside socializing with people because
i also do enjoy that no no okay but like
i think i think you unders you need to
understand
an introverted person is incapable of
being social no no no no no yeah because
because of because either because they
don't have the confidence to be social
or because they don't know how to that's
that's how i see an introvert like like
i i think that's like obviously if
you're introverted you know you're
an introvert doesn't mean like you're
scared of social interaction you know
that might be some introverts yeah
that's not like that's not everything
the scale you know yes there's severity
yeah yeah yeah but like i'd say i'm an
introvert and the best way i can
describe it is that you know i can be a
social person but i have i have this
battery right it's it's my social
battery right and if i don't interact
with people for a long time that battery
like it fills up to the point where it
starts like overflowing to be like okay
i just want to go out and talk all right
but when i go out and socialize that
battery depletes and depletes more
depletes more and sometimes just it just
gets completely [ __ ] empty like you
boys have hang out with me sometimes
where i'm just like i'm just not going
to say a word this time i'm hanging out
i'm just i'm just like you guys can just
talk and i'm just going to sit here is
that is that is that does it have to do
with being introverted though yeah
because because i feel even extroverts
like that no i if you're tired yeah what
i feel with what i've heard about
extroverts that they actually get energy
from interest from social interactions
so they start off the day with an empty
battery and then they go out and
socialize and that's how they energize
themselves right i feel okay yeah so so
if i'm alone for too long i start to get
like like sad and [ __ ] yeah right do you
now yeah so so yeah connor's definitely
bro guys you know i i i invited this guy
well i invited myself over to his house
[Music]
if there's one thing you need to know
about dan you don't invite jen chan
invites himself
the [ __ ] finals well not the finals
but you know tivon versus don juan it
was a league of legends
yeah so you know because i i heard this
guy mentioned that you know he feels
lonely people don't hit him no no no no
no no no no that's because
i got you man let's put some league
let's have a nice drink together let's
hang out and he's like ah you know
excuses no no no no no no no that's not
what happened what the [ __ ] i agreed to
go to something and i i forgot and then
i i went to the thing and it yeah it
wasn't it wasn't that good i rather wish
i watched the league of legends yeah
that's what we were telling me and i was
like oh well yeah
so like going back to the hosting and
you know your your backstory per se so
you are half japanese half turkish yeah
so your mom taught you japanese um my
dad is japanese actually okay okay yeah
and my mom's turkish you know
so you are so
because you're
if i think about her i gotta say
something nice i'm sure she's a lovely
lady that's cute yeah so like how did
you get fluent because you're pretty
damn fluent oh so
we were saying no as someone who also is
you know half not i'm not even half
actually my parents
my you know why i'm half
i was about to be like what are you half
with my parents are fully tied but i
grew up in a different yeah
yeah
so it's half in a sense but like i'm
full blooded side but still i grew up in
another culture and i'm i wouldn't say
i'm like fully fluent in thai you know
yeah um so if you're fluent in a you
know i say like your mother tongue
language like joey is you really have to
go out and study it true so how did you
get fluent in it well
you know i lived in turkey so i didn't
really have to study it yeah because i'm
like surrendered by it yeah but japanese
so um starting from first grade i was
enrolled in a japanese school
until seventh grade right and my dad
never spoke to me in any other language
you know right he was so persistent to
just speak to me in japanese that you
know that's exactly how my mom did yeah
bro see yeah great parenting yeah
exactly now we're fluent look at us
yeah i agree that like that is that is
the hundred percent the way to do it
because other any other method if you
slip up with another language then it
just lets the kid know oh i can get away
with just speaking of this get you
fluent though because i swear you you're
fluent that that takes you up to a
certain level but it doesn't get you
like oh i mean yeah you obviously have
to study it as well yeah i did a lot of
[ __ ] i'm sure you did as well yeah dude
so my dad um
so to go over the story there were like
chores that i can earn money out of by
filling out kanji
so like that the country's studying
[ __ ] textbooks yeah if i like got one
correct i would get like 0.5 turkish
liras which is like you know like 10 yen
or some [ __ ] yeah so you know you got
money for studying well like
i i i
i just got my meal for the day
like i didn't that wasn't a reward in my
house that was like an obligation he was
in a pay-to-win house yeah right
i was like
he came out of the womb haggling
mother cradle trade off a mother
i complete kanji test you give me money
[Music]
but yeah i think that was one of the
biggest incentives for me to actually
learn
money is a big incentive for a lot of
things you know absolutely yeah because
at that age as well like even you know
like 10 cents is like whoa well you know
yeah for sure
like you're trying to get your like ice
cream money for the day you know yeah
that's what you're like focused on how
did you how did you decide on a pricing
system where you're just like yo i'll
hold down 10 counting did that actually
i actually had to haggle with my dad
[Laughter]
obviously so actually you know now that
you guys talk about it yeah actually i
want to kind of go on a huge tangent oh
okay this is trash
whenever i went to your house i can get
with you know all of this and whatnot
yeah there would always be a period
where it's only you and me yeah on your
balcony and we're like reflecting on our
lives yeah
it's it's it's it's like the 5 a.m tour
i'm always gone by like three yeah yeah
yeah i know you're always just like
peace out but then you know gornj is
always like bro why are you so [ __ ] up
tell me about it
you know what you're calling me out now
you're asking that to me you know really
really helped me you know go over stuff
with you because i mean it's a new
perspective that you're adding here
right oh thank you man
like how how i know when i'm going to
bed when i hang out with jan is when i
see the sun
that is
like well the sun's kind of coming up
jen i should probably get to bed right
now i just i just love how you just you
found out how [ __ ] up your life was
because god was like why are you so
[ __ ] up bro
well like he really you know
in detailed fashion he went over certain
like aspects of what we talked about you
know how i ended up doing certain things
some decision making
and you know really like put your own
thought into your answers and your
evaluation that
made me kind of understand oh thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
i think it's the zen like monk state
that yeah that's very true god just sees
things like differently i don't know it
hits differently he sees things through
his third eye he does he does
one random question do people still pick
on you for the way you drink stuff yeah
i mean i mean okay okay have you seen
that celebrate it
here's the thing here's the thing uh in
my entire life no one has ever picked on
me for the way i drink stuff and now
only only as trash data started has
people have i noticed how i drink things
and i've never noticed that before yeah
uh before i started trash taking the
camera thank you
you are kind of forced to strive for
perfection on this show like
any one slip up in our audience just
like gotcha
oh